foreign
in Scotland since 1955.
very ministers in the course of just a
matter of months you cashed the economy
who said mortgage rates sorry you've
taken energy support away from families
most in need now the Prime Minister has
been fined by the police not once but
twice but take donations from
russian-backed donuts and he reports
have stuffed the house a lot with people
like baroness moon but Mr Speaker let's
be clear what we're talking about is the
fact that the leader of the Scottish
conservatives believes that the people
of Scotland should return labor party
members of parliament in this house
rather than Scottish national party
members to this house this wasn't the
message for the people of Scotland quite
clear don't give the Tories what they
want
Mr Speaker actually the the Scottish
conservatives deserve enormous praise
for forcing for forcing actually for
forcing the SMP into abandoning their
completely unworkable fundamentally
flawed deposit return scheme Mr Speaker
the SMP u-turned and listened to the
voices of the Scottish conservatives and
to business and we look forward to
working with them on delivering
something that actually works to deliver
for the people of Scotland and that's
just it
just they can't fix the mess that
Nicholas sturgeon left their party in
how can they possibly fix the mess that
she left Scotland in
[Applause]